okay i don't even know if this were the
topic but this
fascinated the [ __ ] out of it let's go
okay let's go
i want you to see some uh i was just
watching these highlights okay
oh we got a push off there it's going
the other way a foul on raymar prior
[Applause]
and takes the charge he's taken a bunch
of on ball
gets the ball down low double team kicks
it out to brownie james for three ronnie
james gets the three-pointer to fall
[Applause]
that's exactly what i mentioned a few
minutes ago the ball goes three-pointer
kajani wright sets it up he gets the
double
ronnie feeds that he's got a clean
looking jumper
did you see it they got masks
yep on their chin while they playing yep
[ __ ] why
it's a rule
in california they have to have mass but
don't have to wear it
i couldn't believe my eyes when i saw
this okay california this is raisins and
salads
you [ __ ] up everything in california
you you [ __ ] up salads
mandarins and [ __ ] that's what it is
it's [ __ ]
why
it's down they net that [ __ ] wet as [ __ ]
they sweating
what are we doing california
the [ __ ] is this to be fair i think this
is a l.a specific thing i don't care
i was watching it and i didn't even care
about what the kids were i'm like why
are these high schoolers maybe about to
go into college
wearing matt but they have a rule if
they're doing sports indoors they have
to wear a mask but they don't have to
put on their mouth
they can put it underneath their chin
and you know what this epitomized for me
it epitomized what i thought were a lot
of nonsensical rules that nobody can
justify but that were put into place
because of bureaucracy and just
political points
everybody must wear a mask on her face
no just on your body
it is mandatory like
serious
if you don't we'll give you fines
but the mask is only for them i don't
care put it on your ear
what put on your dick huh why why you're
[ __ ] keep the mask on
so a [ __ ] don't kick corona what are we
talking about right now hey listen this
is what are we talking about right now
hey you know what's stupid
they told me that condoms would work and
it didn't work because they told me
you're supposed to [ __ ] with a condom i
mean i had that [ __ ] in my pocket and
start [ __ ] and then she got pregnant
what the [ __ ] is that that's what you're
doing
that's your logic
bruh
that's [ __ ] with a condom in your
pocket and wondering why she got
pregnant this makes no sense that's the
dumbest [ __ ] i've heard today oh man i i
i couldn't believe my eyes when i saw
that it was it was being televised on
espn and nobody was asking nobody's
that's an eye nobody was asking why are
they they're like yeah oh yeah you know
how uncomfortable that must be to have
some [ __ ] just press the bell against
your ears while you're trying to run up
and down the court sweating and [ __ ]
this is stupid the kids know what's
stupid
ah i just saw it and i just couldn't
stop rolling my eyes
okay la you [ __ ] this [ __ ] up
i have nothing to say what are you doing
justification is if that you could think
of i have no clue if i'm being devil's
advocate maybe they want them to be able
to put on the mask as soon as they sit
down or whatever but even if that's the
case
is wet wet over here where all the
[ __ ] sweat of your face
amasses yeah you're gonna put the in
this vine yeah and when they're gonna
sit down they're gonna put a sloppy ass
how about you just have masks wherever
your [ __ ] sit down and whenever
whenever the [ __ ] you sit down you wear
it
wow
those masks were wet oh i am baffled
those masks were wetter than the
japanese prime minister that [ __ ] was
crazy
i couldn't
no no no no
that mess was wet
no b that's
no that's dumb
i i got no more insight i i can't
justify this yeah lebron james a bunch
of other athletes were like yo why these
kids wearing the mask still have to wear
them and so it makes you wonder it's
like
sometimes we get passed down these rules
that we know don't make no sense but we
still follow them because they're the
rules
at a certain point you don't have to
start quite like listen if we're being
honest it's also reasonable
what's the significant harmless it's not
crazy it's not like they're telling you
to give up everything but it is rather
bizarre
that a lot of folks just sideless and be
like okay
they just said okay them the brakes but
if you think about that's how most laws
work yeah so that can't be too much
this one really [ __ ] flew out to my
face but let us know what you guys think
is this god damn something you would
accept how would you feel about this if
this was at your school would it be
something that you're like hell no
but if you wanted to make people less
interested never wearing mask skin
this is another fantastic way to make
them do so
anything else